qui aurait pu imaginer il ya 15 ans
l'extraordinaire développement
d'internet aujourd'hui la france compte
plus de 23 millions d'internautes
l'histoire d'une révolution sur la toile
tout a commencé en 91 nicolas le marine
et daniel luque
ce qui est formidable sur internet c'est
qu'on peut se raconter des choses super
intéressantes froid la visiophonie le
son et l'image c'est le dernier cri de
l'internet
et quand le réseau n'est pas saturé ça
marche c'est vraiment très pratique
j'ai des amis qui sont à l'étranger mon
frère au maroc donc ça me permet de
communiquer en illimité et gratuitement
il y a quinze ans ça c'était de la
science-fiction 1991 naissance d'une
drôle de formule http deux points flash
flash www créé pour l'armée américaine
en 1969 l'internet s'ouvre grand public
on peut aussi se cultiver durant la
pause repas en temps ou musée du louvre
voilà tout en s'amusant avec une toile
de maître sur le problème la vitesse ou
plutôt la lenteur il faut plusieurs
minutes pour afficher une seule image en
la france compte 75 mille internautes
seulement les particuliers sont part du
réseau premières pages personnelles
premier email la machine est lancée et
ne va plus s'arrêter
grâce au moteur de recherche supposons
qu'il n'existe pas de moteur de
recherche
après quoi on aura l'impression d'être
dans une vaste bibliothèque
mais où sont les livres donc les moteurs
de recherche c'est quelque chose de à ce
niveau fondamental 1999 la belle
histoire devient un cauchemar pour
l'industrie du disque avec le premier
site des changes de musique les virus
informatiques sont de plus en plus
violents
après 2000 le haut débit démocratise le
net les ados s'y raconte sur des blogs
les consommateurs pressés ils font leurs
courses
les célibataires cherchent l'âme soeur
et l'on peut visiter le monde entier en
2006 la france compte 24 millions
d'internautes
la sécurité